Sáng 1,5 theo dưới phương, tổng thống mi đôn nân tròm đã tý bán thành gói tại trưởng nân xách, chỉ giá vào khoa 1,5 cho tý bây giờ Mỹ,
cô đáu trợ giúp dịch đời chính phủ đáng cường nắng ngày, bắt đầu từ ngày 3,5 tháng 1,
có loại này được hạ viện thông qua với tỉ lệ sít sau 2 trong 18 thử thuận,
bá hai trong 18 phử chống, sau khi tụng viện phê chuẩn giữa đó.
Bán bà lợt bảo đàu 1 tải trợ trọn năm cho chính phủ lý bán, đến hết tán chính, ngoài trường bóan điên nội diễn
trên cháy sít được tâm nân xách trong thời gian hạy tòàn như vậy là việc thông qua
gọi nân xách khép lại chính tại kéo sai về mi một sự lợt phân bổng, sức thủy nghiên,
như đồng thời cũng bởi giá vòng đảm phá mới, xây quan bỏ đi ngối điện.
Phê zân trủ thì kêu gọi tải cách nhằm tăng cường giám xác tự quan tý bây dí trú và hải quan,
con cơ quan hải quan và bảo tệ biệt dưới. Chúng khi phải cộng hoa nhấn mạnh như cầu dưới chi dù
tìm hoa đậu của bộ này để chính giá rõ đoạn anh ninh. Thử hẳng như rất tạm thơi trú bộ này sẽ diệu lực vào ngày 12.
Đặt cô hồi Mỹ trước, lực đạt được thoảng vừa, các qua này trong thử hẳng ngắn buồn ngày.